a partir de este año 2021 en mexico lo
que antes se conocía como día de la raza
ahora oficialmente se conmemora como día
de la nación pluricultural en
reconocimiento a la diversidad étnica y
lingüística del país esta conmemoración
se da en un contexto de diferendo con
españa por el tema de si se debe o no
pedir perdón por los abusos cometidos
durante la conquista y se da también en
una tendencia de algunos sectores hacia
de colonizar la narrativa histórica y
sostener que américa nunca fue
descubierta como se ha argumentado se da
también en medio de una polémica por la
remoción de la estatua de cristóbal
colón' de una glorieta de la avenida
paseo de la reforma la más importante
del país y la intención de las
autoridades locales de colocar allí un
monumento a la mujer indígena aún por
definir este 2021 también se cumplen 25
años de la conformación del congreso
nacional indígena motivo por el cual
integrantes de comunidades de pueblos
originarios residentes en la capital del
país llevarán a cabo un conversatorio
para recordar la lucha por sus derechos
y sociales